what is the central question a central
question I love I love me a good central
question so central question not to
sound like I'm quoting but I think I
might be so the central question is the
question that once it's definitively
answered yes or no your story is over
so and Central questions
apply to
screenplays for sure and
even TV series like like a season of a
television show might have a central
question for the TV for That season and
each episode might have its own it has
its own central question for
um you know for each episode so it's a
central question is really just the way
to
make sure that you're hitting sort of
the the emotional and intellectual and
um personal
thrust of the story so so really a good
central question has is really like
three components you know it's probably
like you know I think said field called
like professional personal and private
you know um which was this idea that
if you look at like um you know Star
Wars is kind of a classic example that I
use you've ever seen Star Wars okay so
Star Wars um you say what's the the
central question of Star Wars the
professional question is will
um will Luke destroy the Death Star
right the
um
personal question is will he save
Princess Leia
and the private question is will he be a
Jedi like his father
right so if you look at Star Wars you
know the professional personal and
private you go
that all three of those get answered
right at the climax of the movie right
he destroys the Death Star sure he went
in and he saved Princess Leia from the
jail cell but they let him get away
because they would lead him to the rebel
base right and
um
the the way of saving Princess Leia for
real because she's on the planet that
the Death Star is about to destroy right
so the way to save Princess Leia
ultimately is to destroy the Death Star
and the way to destroy the Death Star is
he's got all the technology and stuff
that he's using but he shuts it off and
he uses the force
so in one Fell Swoop right in One Moment
In the climax he uses the force saves
the princess by destroying the Death
Star so the central question is answered
in the affirmative yes yes and yes yeah
will he yeah will he save Princess Leia
yes will he destroy the Death Star yes
will he become a Jedi like his father
yes
movies over right so you know it becomes
very easy and and they don't all have to
be answered yes I mean Dark Knight you
know is interesting it's you know if I
recall the central question of Dark
Knight properly it's you know it's will
will
um Bruce Wayne get the girl is the you
know is the uh you know personal
question right will you fall in love you
know have a relationship with Rachel
professional is will he stop the Joker
and the private is can he can he be the
hero that Gotham City
needs right you know can he rise to that
challenge so you look at it goes well
yeah he defeats the Joker but he doesn't
get the girl right he he loses her and
he becomes it's the great line it's the
it's it's the he becomes the hero that
Gotham doesn't want but Gotham does need
so he does become the hero but not in
the way that he was expecting it so and
that's part of what why Dark Knight is
such a brilliant movie because it it's
very clear on the central questions but
it doesn't it doesn't give you the the
happy ending kind of walk off into the
sunset kind of uh of conclusion
what is the central question for
stitchers
I have to think about that I know I
wrote it once
well the the original it's it's
it depends because central question is
often defined by
the your central character
um like a good central question is is
about like in The Dark Knight
you know example it's about Bruce Wayne
Batman right that's and in Star Wars
it's about Luke so the central question
is really a function of whoever your
main character is right so for for
stitchers without main character being
you know cursed and who had this made up
you know you know illness is temporal
dysplasia you know which which made her
like you know a person who like has like
she's in a who lives in a constant state
of deja vu like everything seems
immediately familiar to her right so the
the professional question is will she
become a part of this government lab
because she's very kind of recruited to
solve help solve a murder even though
they've kind of had her eye on her for a
while so will she become part of this
team it would be like the professional
question the personal question is
um will she be able to develop a
relationship with the male lead you know
Cameron and then the private question is
will she
um really discover what happened to her
you know her mother because there's this
like whole mystery like the mom is you
know is presumed to be dead but isn't
really and I mean there is a way to look
at the central question like how do you
know what's a good central question so
the professional part of the central
question is the thing that means a lot
to a lot of people and the personal part
means a lot to a few people and the
private means a lot to one person so
so going back to Star Wars did you see
Star Wars so going back to start
so going back to Star Wars
destroying the Death Star means a lot
that's a professional question it means
a lot to a lot of people right it's
blowing up planets it's everybody in the
entire galaxy far far away once the
debts got destroyed so destroying the
Death Star means a lot to a lot of
people will Luke save the princess means
a lot to a few people it certainly means
a lot to the princess it means a lot to
the rebels I don't know that saving the
princess means a lot to somebody on some
Planet you know far you know on the
other side of the Galaxy right it
doesn't mean a lot to everybody so it
means a lot to a few will Luke become a
Jedi like his father means a lot to Luke
so so that's a good way to look at your
your central question like what means a
lot to a lot of people a lot to a few
and a lot to one and then that's a good
way to kind of Define your central
question and it helps Focus your your
main character because everybody's kind
of obsessed with you know
character-driven stories and stuff like
that which sounds odd because I I
always approach my stories from a plot
heavy stance first rather than you know
rather than character a character comes
later in some weird way I know this is
like controversial and people will think
that you know I'm an idiot or will
wildly disagree with me about it you
know it's like I'm I'm
espousing some like satanic approach to
storytelling what plot first character
second
I don't know maybe maybe it's because I
like like characters pop into my story
head kind of fully formed so I don't
worry about them
as much as I worry about telling the
getting the plot right
um so yeah it's it's kind of it's sort
of a double-edged sword you know I I
stopped myself I was going to say
something controversial like like
if you have a really well told story
with a poorly constructed main character
you might very well still sell that
because somebody looking and go oh
here's what this character needs to do
to better serve this really well
constructed story
so so because you're going to get notes
and you're going to get Rewritten stuff
like that so if you have a fundamentally
really strong really solid story but
there's some character flaws in the
development of those characters not
character flow like you know they steal
or something like a character flaw in
your construction of that character
um you might still very likely sell that
story
um and then work on the character
afterwards but if you have a really
poorly constructed story but it has a
great character
I don't know I don't know if you're ever
gonna sell that it's just it's too much
it's too much of a heavy lift
you know it's I I I I know maybe I'm
wrong I'd love to hear from people
who've maybe had that experience but to
me with everything I know about the
business and about marketing and about
selling and about what people want or
don't want
it feels to me like it's a much safer
bet to have a strong story with a
character that could use a little bit of
work if the character is terrible I mean
then it's you know but if you're within
spitting distance of a well-constructed
character who's in a really well
constructed story that's far better than
you know you're you know having a
perfectly constructed main character who
saddled with this just useless story
is the central question also a story
engine
um
yes and no it's a story engine to the
extent that it it helps create certain
parameters by which you should tell the
story
um but it's a it's really a litmus test
more than anything else the first main
purpose of the central question is to
Define where Act One ends and where act
two begins because
your your act one is laying all the pipe
for the rest of your story it's the
foundation of the house so your central
question comes in at the end of act one
and I don't mean it comes in like you
know somebody brings in a box and they
go here's your central question but your
your essential question should be
clearly defined at the end of act one
you know so like at the end of act one
in Star Wars again did you see so at the
end of act one in Star Wars
you know um Luke is had his aunt and
uncle killed he's they know that the
princess is in trouble
um Obi-Wan has said you must come with
me if you want to be a Jedi like your
father you know
um and because you know I can't I gotta
go you know milk the space cows or
whatever so you know and then he goes
back home and realizes that news and now
he's got nothing to hold him there and
he comes back and goes there's nothing
to keep me here I want to go with you I
want to save the princess I want to be a
Jedi like my father and that's the end
of act one you know as they're about to
go down into you know Moss Eisley in the
bar and the great you know Cantina scene
um but all those we we know very clearly
what his professional personal and
private Journey now is going to be
through the rest of the story and that's
the landmark that's the the flag that
the Storyteller waves to say act one is
now over it's now time for act two so
you can use as a writer you should use
the central question to help Define your
switch over from act one to act two and
if it's not clear it's like you know I
don't know what my character's main
mission is going to be in the story and
by Mission I don't mean that you got to
go over the restaurant the mission could
be a love story right Mission could be a
medical drama it's like whatever that
professional thing the thing that means
a lot to a lot of people
um that should be clear as should be
that your main character's personal
desire and then the private need of the
character and once that's all clear
that's the end of act one I I can't tell
you the number of
scripts I've consulted on where it's
like you just read it and you're on page
you know 75 and it's still not clear
what your character needs to accomplish
and you go oh my God it's like this is
like a never-ending act one there's so
much fat in there
um yeah so that central question is a
really good litmus test to for you to
say Have I told my Act One properly
that's like building a house if I build
have I built my Foundation properly yep
professional personal private yep done
good let's move on now to the first
floor of the house right you don't want
to build the first floor on a faulty
foundation so it's it's a good test for
that and then
to go to your question of story engine
it's you just it's a story engine only
in that you go oh I got a really great
idea for a scene and you start writing
out that scene you have to ask yourself
is this am I re if am I answering
the central question definitively yes or
no on the professional
storyline the personal storyline or the
private am I moving that part of the
story forward you know in some new way
and if you're not then then it's
probably the wrong scene or beat or
moment because you're not advancing the
story based on the central question so
essential questions not really a story
engine it's just it's that mirror that
you can hold up to your to your story so
that you have a sense of am I am I
satisfying I made my audience a promise
with the central question
everything that comes afterwards has to
honor that promise I promised I would
tell them the story of Luke becoming a
Jedi like his father I promised that I
would tell the story of Luke saving the
princess I promised I will tell the
story about trying to stop the Death
Star and if you look at the story Every
Beat
is something about one of those three
components and you know if it's like cut
to you know Luke goes to a pet shop and
decides that he wants to buy a dog you
go
it might be the sweetest cutest most fun
scene you know in the history of fun
scenes but you know it's not moving the
story forward
and it's actually just going back to
Star Wars again there's plenty of um of
outtakes and and scenes that were shot
that um that exists that you can find
and just watch those scenes and go oh
that's why I didn't make it into the
finished story okay that because it's
not it's not advancing it's it's not
adding another Pearl to the necklace
it's really just
and you know emphasizing a pearl that's
already there and you go you don't need
it right so yeah it's you've got to be
judicious on it that's kind of like
another reason why yeah because I I've
worn many hats in my career when I
started off in editing
um back in the editing rooms in New York
you know in film and sound editing and
you know I just watched the
the anxiety you know as they they would
get all this footage in and say oh my
God they're so overshot
um and stuff they don't need and like
stuff that gets cut out and cut out and
cut out like everybody knows the stories
of like people's performances end up on
The Cutting Room floor and the first cut
of a movie was four and a half hours
long and they finally get it down to you
know 90 minutes you know who's you know
how much time and money that wastes
um like
it's just crazy so so I'm a fan of Leo
construct a really well told story don't
don't fill it with fluff don't have Luke
going to get dogs because it's not gonna
it's not never gonna make it into the
finished
product anyway